you mentioned your husband Karl I know
that you two have been together two
years right we've been together for four
years married for two almost two years
yes okay
married for two years but until this
quarantine you do know yeah we just my
job was that Karl yelling don't answer
that
those are just a couple of lion roll
tiger king doubt now we are we all do we
all do it's normal but no Karl night we
just officially moved in together after
four years of beans isn't that crazy
well maybe it's good I mean maybe that's
kind of healthy like to ease your way in
you know I it's worked great for us I
mean everyone has a million opinions
about what we do right but they were
very just shocked we didn't live
together and but it's been great and now
we just moved in together during the
quarantine and I I like him
oh that's really good
that's really good to be married to
someone to know them for four years and
to have been married to them for two
years and then realized I like this
person now let me ask you a question
yeah it is over and the quarantine is
lifted he's out he's out this is just
for the quarantine right now I'm going
to tell my wife that I'm gonna tell no
one that this is yeah I was just talking
to Kaley Cuoco in her nightgown and yeah
you're out the minute the quarantines
over and her husband's out and you do
the math yeah why you know I want to ask
you something about your husband because
he sounds like a very cool guy Carl cook
he's an equestrian but he's also a like
championship level gardener is that true
yes
so he even says now he's graduated from
gardening to farming he's an amazing
farmer he grows all of our food
he actually this is a very interesting
fact about my very strange adorable
husband he is a an award-winning pumpkin
grower
I'm just letting that silence hang right
there you know what the nice thing is
there's no audience so I can just let
horrible it's horrible no no I like it
in this situation because you went he's
an award-winning pumpkin grower
no but you know what I know something
about pumpkin growing because my uncle
my dad's brother was an award-winning
pumpkin grower out wife yes and he grew
pumpkins out in Sturbridge Massachusetts
and he knew how to make that make the
pumpkins and you haven't lived till
you've seen pumpkins get oh I am so
amazed that you even know anything about
this it is very serious business like
the cross-pollination and the whole
thing they have to meet they have to the
pumpkins have to mate yes and sometimes
if a pumpkins shy you have to give them
a lot of privacy and music helps but you
pumpkins together and then these
pumpkins get competitive pumpkin growers
take it really seriously get to be like
you know like as heavy as a truck frac
yes his his first attempt ended up to be
about a hundred pounds and I actually I
asked him to send me a photo last night
he was like it wasn't my best year and I
was like a hundred pound pump yeah I
mean this is these are the things that
that he does but he grows everything was
funny when this whole quarantine started
I was like oh my god you got even get
our produce and our this and he's like
babe we're gonna live off the land and
I'm like how long have you wanted to say
that we're gonna he was a long while he
was very excited you can live in the
pumpkin you can hollow these those
things out that's like three thousand
square feet of living space in a party
huge no they aren't really shockingly
huge and I asked him I said how did you
learn how to do that and he said you too
yeah you too pumpkin sex you learn you
can well there's all kinds of sex stuff
on YouTube there is not just pumpkin
stuff what's yeah there's squat you can
see squash going at it you can see
turnips you can see arugula I've watched
three ways with arugula and leeks
[Music]
yeah